lionel jospin n'apaise pas la grogne des
chômeurs qui appelle à continuer le
mouvement manifestation nationale prévue
mardi nombreuses réactions mesures
annoncées par le gouvernement dont un
milliard de francs pour un fonds
d'urgence sociale nous rejoindront en
direct claire villiers pour
l'association agir ensemble contre le
chômage et en duplex de bretagne à la
madeleine un contrat local de sécurité
pour mieux lutter contre les violences
urbaines des adjoints de sécurité en
renfort dès aujourd'hui dans plusieurs
communes à l'initiative de jean pierre
chevènement en marge des affaires de
dopage dans le milieu des compétitions
l' enquête sur la banalisation de la
prise de produit chez les sportifs du
dimanche
et puis découverte des nouvelles
tendances au salon du meuble ouvert à
paris demain au grand public de la
couleur et en vedette le plastique du
plus simple au plus sophistiqué
madame monsieur bonsoir répondre à
l'urgence sociale et ouvrir les chemins
de l'espoir voilà en substance avec ces
quelques mots du premier ministre la
couleur de la conférence de presse tenue
ce matin par lionel jeu spa ou 30e jour
du mouvement des chômeurs nous
reviendrons dans ce journal
sur l'ensemble des mesures proposées
nous écouterons les réactions temps
syndical que politique
mais d'abord voyons comment la balle a
réagi l'exemple à marseille
là où le mouvement a débuté sur place la
déception et la colère
yannick a aussi vincent de vendre nous
savons que la première attente d une
rumeur concitoyens dans leur ensemble
la priorité c'est l'emploi au trentième
jour de l'occupation toutes les oreilles
sont tournés vers l'hôtel matignon
lionel jospin repose et s'engage email
ne convainc pas
ces valeurs que nous sommes tous les
chômeurs doit être payé immédiatement
c'est à dire au maire à ce même à de
mars on a l'impression que des cours et
chômeurs on dirait cavale qui vient le
gouvernement afin que tu viennes au
gouvernement et il ça n'existait pas
dans toutes les antennes occuper les
réactions sont semblables un brin de
satisfaction devant la prise en compte
du mouvement est beaucoup d'amertume
devant des mesures jugées insuffisantes
il ya en fait à les ouled ya pas d aide
il nous disait simplement arrêter
dassier a siégé les assedic on vous a
compris mais ils ont rien compris à ce
qu'on voulait pas là c'est terrible
moi je sais pas mais c'est révoltant
même temps que des trucs comme ça on ne
moufte pas en assemblée générale ce midi
les militants cgt ont clairement affiché
leurs intentions pour la suite de
l'action il travaille maintenant à la
mobilisation pour la manifestation qui
réunira chômeurs et salariés mardi
prochain ont déferlé dans les quartiers
nous ne laisserons plus le gouvernement
un seul moment de répit parce qu'il nous
entende l'appel
on va savoir les saisir on ne le ferai
plus nous nous dicter leur loi parce
qu'on en a marre qu'on nous dit que le
roi et nous on accepte tout ce qu'on
nous dit ça c'est fini c'est terminé
ils sentent que leur mouvement prend un
nouvel essor une nouvelle légitimité
les chômeurs veut aller jusqu'au bout
pour tenter d'obtenir la prime de 3000
francs leur revendication première c'est
donc le premier ministre qui est monté
en première ligne pour tenter de
répondre à la détresse des chômeurs lors
d'une conférence de presse ce matin par
et en présence de martine aubry
l'angoissent des sans emploi dont
parlent les neiges stanley coutin quel
que soit le nombre de ceux qui se sont
engagés dans ces mouvements
je sais le poids que fait peser le
chômage prolongé sur des centaines de
milliers de personnes
au-delà de la question immédiate de la
réforme des fonds sociaux de l'unedic
nous y voyons le témoignage d'une
détresse d'un désarroi profond que
vivent beaucoup de personnes privées
d'emploi accablé
le problème matériel l'opinion publique
ne s'y est pas trompé d'autant que la
période des fêtes de fin d'année a rendu
par contraste ces situations encore plus
intolérable
voyons maintenant dans le détail les
mesures proposées par le gouvernement
sans changer de cap économique
lionel jospin propose des mesures en
deux temps création d'un fonds d'urgence
sociale est remise à plat des structures
d'indemnisation les explications avec
jean paul chapelle le premier ministre a
créé ce matin un fonds d'urgence sociale
pour les chômeurs en grande difficulté
un milliard de francs apportés par
l'état qui pourrait être complétée par
d'autres contributions celle des
conseils généraux des allocations
familiales et des assedic une experte
des questions sociales marie thérèse
join lambert est chargé d'une double
mission d'abord pérenniser les cellules
départementales d'urgence chargé
d'examiner les cas des chômeurs en
détresse ensuite réfléchir à
l'articulation entre les systèmes
d'assurance chômage de solidarité et des
minima sociaux par ailleurs le
gouvernement souhaite que les
associations de chômeurs soit
représentée à l'anpe dans des comités
d'usagers enfin le premier ministre a
promis pour le mois de mars un projet de
loi avec des réformes en profondeur pour
lutter contre l'exclusion et les
réactions au dispositif du gouvernement
ne se sont pas fait attendre d'abord
celle des syndicats lionel jospin en
préambule a réaffirmé qu'ils étaient
bien les partenaires naturels de la
négociation il ya du positif parce
qu'elle porte un certain nombre de
mesures d'urgence
immédiate qui ne sont pas négligeables
même si on pouvait considérer qu'elle
aurait dû être plus forte mais surtout
parce que ces premières mesures sincères
dans toute une série de chantiers que le
ministre annonce et qui vont constituer
autant de champs d'intervention pour
persévérer et faire en sorte que des
réponses à la fois plus fiable plus
durable et correspondant plus à ce
qu'attendent les chômeurs se
construisent à milliards ce n'est pas
rien aux c'est pas suffisant il en
faudrait beaucoup plus
néanmoins ça permettra de prendre en
charge ce qui sauvera les circonstances
et dans les situations les plus
désespérées
ça ne règle pas le contentieux pour
autant il faut le dire clairement
mais il a fait ce qu'il devait faire et
ce qu'il pouvait faire et je pense que
ce n'est pas négligeable
maintenant il reste le reste et le reste
c'est surtout essayer d'offrir aux
chômeurs à travail plutôt qu'une
allocation aussi bonne soit elle et pour
sa part la cfdt prend acte des mesures
annoncées mais regrette qu'il n'y ait
pas de relèvement des minimas sociaux
comme elle l'avait demandé enfin aucun
commentaire du clvf si le discours de
lionel jospin a trouvé un certain écho
chez les partenaires sociaux comme nous
venons de l'entendre en revanche il n'a
pas convaincu apparemment la plupart des
militants des associations
retour sur le terrain à gennevilliers
dans une année où les chômeurs décide de
poursuivre le mouvement
reportage olivier carrosse yanncik l île
n'applaudissent pas les propositions du
gouvernement mais bien au contraire la
décision de poursuivre l'occupation de
cet ape
depuis hier ils sont quelques dizaines
de chômeurs mécontents ce matin après
avoir entendu le discours de lionel
jospin
ils laissaient éclater leur colère
c'est un peu pareil c'est pas possible
cette fois de notre gueule en plus il a
passé un quart d'heure à délayer son
truc à rien dire c'est ta langue de bois
et on n'est pas dupe on n'est pas du
tout à fait que la gauche seuil fasquel
au pouvoir entre les promesses et puis
et puis les actes on l'a vu pour les
sans papiers on l'a vu pour plein de
choses on l'a vu pour les mal logés on
l'a vu pour les chômeurs en belgique on
s'engage la reconnaissance par un gang
et de nos associations de chômeurs après
cinq jours de lutte ce que craignait
avant tout les responsables de ces
actions
c'était la démobilisation mais les
militants ont vite repris des forces ils
avaient un petit moment d'abattement
après les mesures annoncées qui étaient
insuffisantes
mais en réalité quelques heures après ce
qui a pris le dessus c'est la volonté de
pas en rester là
on va montrer notre détermination ça
c'est clair à l'unanimité moins quatre
voies ils ont décidé d'occuper les
locaux tout le week end
une façon de compter ses troupes qui
commencent parfois fatigue
le premier ministre après avoir reçu
hier à matignon les associations de
chômeurs reconnaît implicitement et à
travers un prochain statut l'existence
de ces associations
mais il tient le discours de la fermeté
en demandant expressément l'évacuation
des assedic occupé en écoute je pense
que l'occupation de lieux publics
destinés au public ou privé les assedic
sont privés donc je corrige les services
sociaux publics ou privés qui ont comme
mission de répondre aux chômeurs qui
leur permettent de s'inscrire ou qui
leur permettent de toucher leurs
indemnités ne peut pas être une forme
est maintenant de l'action autant dit
tati une forme permanente de l'action
revendicative
nous rejoignons tout de suite en direct
claire villiers pour l'association agir
ensemble contre le chômage
bonsoir vous venez d'entendre le
discours de fermeté ou réentendre le
discours de lionel jospin qui demande
l'évacuation des acryliques
alors concrètement allez vous oui ou non
changer votre forme d'actions autrement
dit vous avez entendu l'appel du premier
ministre
j'ai très bien entendu l'appel du
premier ministre
c'est surtout entendu les propositions
de monsieur jospin ses décisions je
trouve
d'autres qu'il y avait effectivement des
points qui ne sont pas négligeables
néanmoins je voudrais dire que c'est
exclusivement la mobilisation des
chômeurs qui les ont acquis et moi j'ai
surtout entendu les reportages que vous
avez diffusé là qu'ils ont à présent à
la fois à marseille et à gennevilliers
et je crois que ce que partagent
aujourd'hui ce soir la grande majorité
de ceux qui sont en lutte mais également
tous les chômeurs qui les regardent qui
se sentent représentés par ce mouvement
c'est un peu de la colère de la rage
mais beaucoup de détermination
notre mouvement a déjà apporté quelque
chose
nous voulons aller plus loin alors à
l'heure qu'il est il y a dix huit
bureaux antennes assedic et plusieurs
autres organismes qui sont toujours
occupées par les chômeurs est ce que
vous comptez n'est tenir jusqu'à mardi
jour de la manifestation nationale je
voudrais dire d'abord que s'il ya
aujourd'hui 18 bureaux qui sont occupées
c'est pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que des dizaines ont été évacués par les
forces de police aujourd'hui et dans
beaucoup d'endroits depuis maintenant
une semaine les assedic les agences pour
l'emploi et d'autres services sont
fermées au public c'est absolument
inacceptable quand nous occupons nous
n'empêchons pas les services de
fonctionner ça n'est absolument pas
notre but
ce que nous allons faire dans les jours
qui viennent c'est que nous allons
discuter dans tous les lieux occupés
nous allons discuter avec les chômeurs
partout où nous les rencontrons dans les
villes sont les marchés ce week-end et à
bien d'autres endroits
nous allons porter une appréciation
commune mais je crois que le sentiment
qui dominera c'est que nous voulons que
ce mouvement qui encore une fois a
apporté les choses à fond d'urgence une
mise à plat d'indemnisation du chômage
une des comités d'usagers dans les
agences pour l'emploi une reconnaissance
des associations
nous voulons continuer parce que nous
voulons absolument un relèvement tout de
suite des minima sociaux en particulier
le rmi et la ss parce qu'on ne peut pas
vivre avec 2000 francs il n'ya rien
opposée à une telle considération et
nous voulons que pour les jeunes de
moins de 26 ans qui sont interdits du et
rémy il y est
ouverture d'un droit à une allocation
les partenaires sociaux et sont plutôt
satisfaits des mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement pour quelles raisons votre
discours est loin de weiler et celui de
la déception apparemment et bien tout
simplement parce que je crois que nous
et nous organisons nous essayons de
représenter les chômeurs est ce que nous
disons ce soir c'est ce que vivent des
millions d'hommes et de femmes dans ce
pays de six millions qui vivent avec les
minima sociaux et évidemment c'est c'est
leur volonté de changer leurs conditions
de vie c'est aussi leur espoir
l'appel au gouvernement est très fort
mais je dirais c'est aussi une
interpellation au patronat c'est quand
même les entreprises qui sont les
grandes pourvoyeuses de chômage le
patronat se fait extrêmement discret on
a même entendu des hommes de droite qui
étaient des ministres du précédent
gouvernement
dire qu'il trouvait notre mouvement
légitime je regrette qu'il ne l'ait pas
trouvé dans les années précédentes
nous allons continuer interpellé agir
pour l'emploi
nous allons agir dans le cas de la
proposition de loi pour les 35 heures
mais nous allons surtout continuer ou
qu'il y est je le répète à une un
relèvement des minimas sociaux merci
madame lise et d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions et alain madelin sera
interrogé dans quelques instants je
propose d'abord d'écouter les réactions
politiques l'opposition critiqué la
politique du gouvernement
robert hue pour sa part réclament des
réformes plus profondes
le premier ministre a donné at au
chômeur de la légitimité de leur
mouvement il a reconnu que cette
exigence de dignité elle était tout à
fait légitime je me réjouis de cela et
et le fonds social d'urgence d'un
milliard qui est qui et donc créer me
semble un un pas important mais il ouvre
sur d'autres chantiers il faut
naturellement plus il faut d'ailleurs
des mesures structurelles qu'à évoquer
le premier ministre le premier ministre
reconnaît qu'il a perdu sept mois ils
redécouvrent après sept mois à matignon
kylie a dans ce pays d aix plus
finalement le premier ministre à montrer
le décalage très grand entre sa
perception de la réalité et la réalité
rejoignant maintenant el ahmed la
président de démocratie libérale en
direct de rennes bonsoir ces derniers
jours où vous vous êtes dit révolté par
cette passivité que l'on a à vis à vis
du chômage vous parler de manque de
courage
depuis des années alors comment jugez
vous ce soir les mesures du gouvernement
vous y voyez un peu d'audace n'ont pas
beaucoup d'otages y voit un peu la
panoplie classique d'un gouvernement
classique on a eu le premier ministre
madame la ministre de l'emploi les
lambris de matignon nombre de bois un
peu technocratique une rallonge
budgétaire des comités locaux soul
l'autorité des préfets
une madame emplois de plus une énième
réflexion de plus bon c'est mieux que
rien c'est mieux que rien mais c'est moi
je suis révolté par cette affaire du
chômage depuis longtemps il
particulièrement du chômage de longue
durée parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter
dans un pays qui malgré tout est un pays
riche comme la france que tonnes
familles françaises se trouvent
aujourd'hui enfermées dans l'assistance
se sentent inutiles se sentent rejetés
le sentiment que leurs enfants autant
trop se sacrifie vraiment parfois dans
les conditions extrêmement difficiles
pour faire en sorte que leurs enfants
soient des enfants comme les autres ce
sens y arriver vraiment alors c'est vrai
que je trouve que cette révolte elle est
un peu la révolte des politiquement
faible contre contre les médiatiquement
fort et si elle dérange elle dérange
tant mieux moi je suis pas dans
l'opposition je voudrais faire une
proposition si vous voulez et à la place
de monsieur jospin voilà ce que j'aurais
fait je dis voilà vous les maires vous
pouvez créer des des emplois sortes
d'emplois d'utilité collective au
service des personnes âgées au service
de l'environnement pour l'animation de
vos villes et ces emplois vous devez les
réserver à celle de ceux qui sont
complètement enfermé dans le chômage qui
n'ont aucune chance d'avoir un véritable
emploi dans une véritable entreprise au
moins dans un premier temps et que l'on
nous donne la possibilité à nous les
maires de prendre les ces minimums
sociaux ces allocations de misère en
rajoutant un petit quelque chose pour
les transformer en activité
il a utilisé la collectivité moi ce que
j'ai entendu dans le message des
chômeurs s'est pas seulement demandent
un subside de plus bien sûr on demande
d'améliorer la situation
mais ce qu'on demande surtout c'est un
travail et ses emplois d'utilité
collective il existe sur le terrain
malheureusement monsieur le premier
ministre madame aubry au lieu de les
donner à ceux qui en auraient le plus
besoin on en fait des perspectives
d'avenir pour des jeunes et qui plus est
de jeunes diplômés je crois que c'est
une erreur qu'il faut revenir en arrière
merci monsieur madelin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions à l'elysée pour la
traditionnelle galette des rois jacques
chirac a réaffirmé que le chômage
l'exclusion et la violence était un
souci permanent pour beaucoup d'entre
nous par ailleurs le chef de l'état a
dénoncé une nouvelle fois la création
d'emplois'' artificielle et souligné que
la réduction du temps de travail était
nécessaire mais ne constitué pas la
solution au chômage
fin de citation voilà pour la politique
autre sujet qui préoccupe au lendemain
de la tornade qui a dévasté plusieurs
villages dans le pas-de-calais
l'heure est à la solidarité serrer les
coudes pour réparer les dégâts à nous
mourgues patrick the storm soir paul
dormira dans cette bâtisse une ancienne
ferme prêté par un voisin
il pourra même s'ils le souhaitent y
rester quelques mois voilà ce qu'il
reste de sa maison à lui après le
passage de la tornade dans le village
la solidarité s'organise on comprendre
que tout le monde connaît bien le sol il
est en campagne
c'est pourquoi ça vous fait chaud au
coeur
ouais près de 50 personnes ont ainsi été
relogés partout on s'active pour réparer
les dégâts
certains viennent même des communes
voisines ramasser les tuiles refaire une
toiture
isabelle est bénévole à la croix-rouge
elle a rencontré des dizaines de
sinistrés ont pas ce que vous demandez
s'il donne quelque chose de la
nourriture
non là ça va elle suit ses maisons
quelques questions quelques mots de
réconfort c'est très important surtout
pour le moral dans les talons étaient
hier
ah ouais on a attrapé un coup à ma femme
un petit peu près du coeur et ça lui a
fait du bien à la mairie
des dizaines de coups de téléphone de
visite pour des dons pour proposer de
l'aide
on a entendu l'appel à la radio comme
quoi que il banques et d'une couchage
des couvertures pour les gens ils sont
dehors qu'ils ont pu de toiture au plus
de portes est naturellement qu'est ce
qu'on en fait environ 0 on n'a pas des
couvertures qu'on donne ici aussi
même s'il n'y a personne à reloger
chacun s'affaire pour que les fidèles
puissent dès dimanche
retrouvez leur église au japon la neige
paralyse la ville de tokyo de grosses
tempêtes de neige ont touché la capitale
la nuit dernière provoquant la mort
d'une personne et faisant près de 500
blessées la plupart ayant glissé sur le
verglas le trafic aérien et ferroviaire
contraire perturbé des centaines ou de
milliers de personnes n'ont pu regagner
les banlieue de tokyo
seule bonne nouvelle la neige au rendez
vous pour les jeux olympiques de nagano
qui doivent débuter dans un mois au
canada maintenant près d'un tiers de la
population québécoise toujours privés
d'électricité les dégâts provoqués par
des pluies verglaçantes sont
considérables et la tempête continue de
paralyser la région personne n'était
mieux placé pour en parler qu'un
correspondant québécois son nom et reale
damour
or apparemment nous avons un problème
avec ce sujet nous le verrons un peu
plus tard
passant au reste de l'actualité pour
lutter contre les violences urbaines en
france jean-pierre chevènement propose
des contrats de sécurité ou plan local
c'est à givors ce matin que le ministre
de l'intérieur est venu signer ce
premier pacte entre la justice la police
et la commune tous réunis autour d'un
même objectif la coopération pour venir
à bout de l'insécurité
voyons maintenant sur le terrain l'un
des volets de ce dispositif il s'agit
d'affecter deux nouveaux adjoints de
sécurité pour assister les policiers au
quotidien
une mesure qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
des emplois jeunes l'exemple à givors
dans le rhône reportage benoît gadret
thiery simonet vincent 22 ans est
adjoint de sécurité depuis une quinzaine
de jours la police il la connaît déjà
il y a fait son service militaire une
expérience précieuse pour affronter les
situations conflictuelles découvert pas
mal de choses j'ai su faire abstraction
des insultes par extraction de pas mal
de petits heures qu'on peut avoir avec
la population tout en toujours en
restant courtois en essayant de trouver
une solution au problème des personnes
dans la rue on les reconnaît à la
couleur bleu électrique de leurs
épaulettes
ils n'ont pas le statut de fonctionnaire
il dispose d'un contrat d'un an
renouvelable cinq fois et sont payés au
smic c'est un boulot qui en continu et
qui demande beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup d'intentions et je pense que
ceux qui seront leurs acquis tous
devront faire ce métier pour juste le
salaire ils seront vite repéré et ils
ont beaucoup d'avenir dans la police je
pense six semaines de formation et des
compétences limitées
l'accueil l'îlotage avant tout assure
une présence même s'ils sont armés ils
ne sortent pas seul pas d'intervention à
police-secours pas d'enregistrement de
plainte d'un côté je vois ça d'un bon
oeil parce que on a besoin de personnel
ici à givors et puis d'un autre côté ça
il faut pas voir cette arrivée l'adjoint
de sécurité comme la solution que l'on
attendait aux problèmes d'effectif dans
la mesure où au niveau de leur tâche ils
sont quand même assez limité
paradoxalement entre les quatre appelé
les quinze adjoints de sécurité pour
chaque brigade de ce commissariat il y
aura prochainement plus de policiers
auxiliaires que deux policiers
professionnels depuis un mois dans les
alpes-maritimes les policiers municipaux
sont mobilisés pour dénoncer
l'avant-projet de loi de jean pierre
chevènement qui vise notamment à les
désarmer ou cannes et la police
municipale a décidé de lancer une
pétition l'opération est réussie
au delà de leurs espérances laisse mina
farber et didier beaumont dans les
bureaux de la police municipale du
cannet l'huissier de justice et peluches
laborieusement les vins
508 bulletin de soutien signée par la
population la commune compte 42 mille
habitants dont 23 mille électeurs pour
les agences et le signe de la
mobilisation générale
le refus de l'avant projet de loi
chevènement on s'aperçoit que tous les
cas des fumoirs sont concernés par la
sécurité et qui veulent leur police
municipale qui peut jamais tenir en est
à savoir 24 heures sur 24 armée sur la
surveillance sur la prévention dans les
squares de partout là où justement ils
ont besoin de sécurité
en 26 jours les 60 agents du cannet on
ratissait la commune pour plaider leur
cause notamment le maintien du port
d'armes
j'estime qu'une police sont forts de ces
peines police elle s'en sert pas
vraiment mais service iad
je pense qu'ils ont déjà pas beaucoup
moins pour défendre alors sur le relève
le peu qu'ils ont c'est pas la peine je
voudrais savoir pour quelles raisons
mais la principale
alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire juste
pour faire le passage piéton fort de ce
soutien les policiers municipaux ont
cessé leur mouvement de grève
les chefs des polices municipales
françaises soit être reçus en délégation
à matignon pour parler de l'avenir de
leur statut retour au canada maintenant
près d'un tiers de la population
québécoise toujours privés d'électricité
les dégâts provoqués par des pluies
verglaçantes sont considérables et la
tempête continue de paralyser la région
leur personne n'était mieux placé pour
en parler qu'un correspondant québécois
son nom est réel d'amour vous
connaissiez mon pays c'est l'hiver de
gilles vigneault
découvrez maintenant une facette de
cette blanche solitude qui tourne à la
catastrophe depuis lundi les régions du
sud est du québec ont reçu par endroits
de 50 à 80 millimètres de verglas de
cuisinière plus d'un million d'abonnés
d'hydro québec sont plongés dans le noir
c'est le tiers du québec
la couche de glace qui recouvre les fils
électriques ne cesse de s'épaissir les
pylônes croule alors que les poteaux
cède 1 à 1
pendant que les transformateurs explose
presqu'aussi le buggy tracas de la gare
et xavier les clés également les la
vision est apocalyptique des milliers de
pâté de maisons sont isolées par des
arbres et branches brisées qui longe le
sol gênant la circulation et surtout les
travaux de remise en marche du service
des lecteurs voici le territoire le plus
affecté
saint-hyacinthe au sud-est de montréal
et dans le noir depuis plus de 48 heures
sans électricité ni chauffage ondes
abandonne les maisons pour se réfugier
dans des gymnases d'écoles dont des
hôpitaux à ces gens encore un peu plus
au sud est de montréal
la ville s'est transformée en un décor
de givre 90% de ces quarante mille
habitants est aussi privé d'électricité
toutes les équipes d'hydro-québec soit
plus de 3000 travailleurs sont à pied
d'oeuvre et s'affèrent 24 heures par
jour à mondes et des arbres à briser la
glace sur les fils électriques et à
tenter de rétablir des circuits avec
plus ou moins de succès à eux se sont
joints également mille autres
spécialistes des états nord amérique
puis 3000 militaires sont également
entrés en scène nous sommes aguerris aux
hivers rigoureux mais nous restons
toujours aussi démuni de rang ce verglas
qu'il ne cesse de tomber depuis dimanche
reale damour radio canada montréal en
1/2 français retenu depuis deux ans ont
été autorisés à quitter le pays pour une
période de quatre mois les deux hommes
sont accusés d'espionnage mathieu chez
deux ans durant martin aura contempler
les aquarelles et autres pastel envoyé
par son mari françois prisonniers au
bout du monde
un époux retenu en inde et soupçonnés
d'espionnage pour avoir organisé des
recherches sous marines
bord d'un catamaran ce soir la justice
indienne vient de les autoriser
lui et son compagnon à rentrer en france
pour quatre mois avant de revenir en mai
prochain pour être fixés sur leur sort
pour sa femme premier soulagement quand
il a été en prison pendant cinq mois il
ya eu des périodes très longues il ya eu
des moments où pendant deux mois j'étais
absolument sans nouvelles il y avait
complètement struction sur le courrier
et tout est élu et surveiller françois
et philippe ici devant leur catamaran
vivent depuis plusieurs mois libre mais
sous surveillance
ils ont toujours affirmé être innocent
selon eux ils venaient découvrir une
épave
rien d'autre après une bataille
juridique que les autres membres de
l'expédition avait déjà été libéré en
mars 97 françois et philippe vont
retrouver leurs proches
un geste symbolique et diplomatique à
quelques jours de la visite officielle
de jacques chirac prévu à la fin du mois
au pays basque nouvel attentat de letea
c'est encore un élu du parti populaire
qui en a été la victime appelle à la
mobilisation après le décès du
conseiller municipal victime d'une
explosion dans une voiture piégée
on avait piégé sa voiture ce matin josé
ignacio et roanne à goiana est mort une
heure après avoir eu les deux jambes
sectionnées par l'explosion d'une bombe
âgé de 34 ans conseiller municipal du
parti populaire le parti au pouvoir en
espagne
l'homme est le premier élu assassinés
depuis le début de l'année sans doute
par le ter cet après midi la réunion du
conseil municipal a été houleuse l'élu
déry batasuna aile politique de l'eau
terrain ne condamne pas l'attentât la
réaction et violents combats
le premier ministre espagnol josé maria
aznar est venue ce soir se recueillir
dans la chapelle ardente où repose le
corps
demain plusieurs manifestations sont
prévues au pays basque
hier dans l'île des canaries en espagne
une tentative de suicide collectif de 31
membres d'une secte a été déjoué par la
police
une majorité d'étrangers accompagné de
quatre enfants comptait se suicider
persuadé de l'imminence de la fin du
monde
cette secte pour être liée à celle du
temple solaire retour en france les
défenseurs de la langue française
partent en campagne au coeur de leurs
préoccupations
la grammaire en politique faut-il dire
madame la ministre ou madame le ministre
la réponse des académiciens qui ne
traite pas le sujet à la légère thibault
de barbeyrac madame la ministre aubry
madame la ministre vous année madame la
ministre guigou elles sont huit au
gouvernement de lionel jospin et l on
féminise et leurs fonctions vouloir les
en empêcher comme essaient de le faire
l'académie française revient pour elle à
défendre une thèse rétrograde
ça me fait penser on savait aux
déclarations vos interrogations du
concile de trente qui se demandaient si
les femmes avaient une âme donc je crois
qu'on a un peu dans le même type de
débat ce qui prouve plus profondément
que le combat pour la dignité des femmes
n'est jamais gagnée et que le une haute
autorité comme l'académie puisse
soulever les problèmes comme cela et ça
prouve que les femmes encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir
madame royal par le droit de la femme
sous la coupole
on lui répond grammaire dans la
grammaire française n'y a pas de neutre
peut bien avait en latin grec et dans
d'autres langues et des langues est issu
du latin
nous n'avons pas neutre donc il ya des
cas où de métier de genre d'espèces
animales ou c'est le masculin qui
représente l'ensemble de l'espace semble
du genre
pour les académiciens dont féminiser le
mot ministre revient pas faire une
distinction entre hommes et femmes
une ségrégation qui va à l'encontre de
l'égalité des sexes
c'est un homme jacques chirac à qui il
revient maintenant de trancher
peut-être demande rate il conseille à
une honteuse ou à une écrivaine
québécoise et si le débat s'enflamme il
devra sans doute se réfugier en belgique
pour solliciter l'aide d'une saps
pompière en france les automobiles sens
de mieux en mieux entretenues mêlant
positifs publiés aujourd'hui par la
sécurité routière qui indique que le bon
entretien des voitures fait baisser le
nombre des accidents valérie gaget
jacques garnier en 97 près de huit
millions de voitures particulières ont
passé un contrôle technique
environ une sur cinq présentaient des
défauts majeurs ce qui oblige le
propriétaire à subir une contre visite
après réparation mais le nombre de
véhicules non conformes diminuent
globalement les automobiles sont de
mieux en mieux entretenu le système de
contrôle technique remplit parfaitement
sa fonction qui est d'améliorer le parc
automobile et quand on sait que le
véhicule est en cause dans à peu près 18
% des cas d'accident mortel pour une
part bien sûr on voit l'importance que
ce sujet présente pour la sécurité
routière
près de 10% des véhicules non conformes
présente un problème de freinage
en second lieu viennent les défauts au
niveau de l'éclairage puis la pollution
émise par le pot d'échappement
sans surprise ce sont les voitures de 11
ans et davantage qui passe le plus mal
le contrôle technique laine est le
département où l'on est le plus souvent
recalés la haute corse celui où les
voitures passent le contrôle le plus
facilement avec la creuse le cantal la
corrèze et le gers en 98 le contrôle
technique sera obligatoire pour tous les
véhicules atteignant l'âge de 4 ans
ainsi que pour ceux déjà contre orléans
95 et en 96 il n'est plus question de le
rendre annuel
découverte à présent avec les nouvelles
tendances au salon du meuble designer et
fabricants proposeront pour une journée
unique demain à paris du plus
sophistiquées au plus traditionnels les
matières en vedette le plastique et de
la couleur encore de la couleur
reportage anthérieu frédéric de l'arrêt
pour love groove élu créateur de l'année
un meuble soit d'abord est-ce conforta
exemple ce canapé ou le bras se repose
dans l'accoudoir en creux voyez aussi
cette chaise longue
grâce à son repose pieds ou l'utilisent
de deux manières
pour détendre ses jambes bien sûr mais
aussi peau et travailler avec son
ordinateur
ici il n'y a pas de technologie c'est
juste une idée
le français péricaud a eu lui aussi une
idée une bibliothèque ronde dans
laquelle on se love avec son livre
nouveau ce poste de travail ordinateur
son tableau en 2000 serre permet une
grande économie de gestes à part le bois
du bio tout est en plastique dans cette
cuisine plastique dur pour le plan de
travail plastique souple et coloré pour
les casiers en plastique encore ses
étagères qui se clipse sur une cornière
métalliques
ce système est courant dans les ateliers
les bricoleurs pascal bour r on a fait
une bibliothèque modulable voici le
fauteuil le plus vendus actuellement
également en plastique lors diot a été
créée par l'une des stars du design
philippe starck la résine de synthèse
encore un plastique remplace le bois
d'eilat sur ces chaises de café un coup
de jeune pour ce mobilier créé il ya
plus d'un siècle davantage sont très
légères casser les trois bâtiments et
qu'elles sont plus confortables ou
conviviales avec le plastique on a
l'intervention de la couleur la couleur
un choix délibéré de l'italien aidera
pour ses fauteuils et canapés
il ya 20 ans et par les formes que les
italiens agressait et créer des meubles
innovants ce rôle est dévolu aujourd'hui
à la couleur les français comme sina
préfère un style moderne sans
provocation un chic pour lequel les
amateurs fortunés n'hésitent pas à
casser leur tirelire en marge des
affaires de dopage qui éclabousse le
milieu de haute compétition les français
accros de sport serait tenté aussi
d'utiliser pour augmenter leurs
performances des produits
pharmaceutiques de la banalisation des
produits dopants
l'enquète de florent gautreau et
philippe luzi il y a 6 mois il refusait
de témoigner à visage découvert cet
ancien champion de france de hockey sur
gazon avait du mal à parler de son passé
de sportif
accro à l'héroïne aujourd'hui frédéric
nordman a tout arrêté le sport et la
drogue et il parle car pour lui le
dopage est une forme de toxicomanie il
ya du dopage à tous les niveaux quand on
sait ce qui se passe avec les équipes de
gamin quand on sait ce qui se passe avec
le sportif du dimanche
faire du sport sans prendre de produits
sa part est quelque chose de tout à fait
étonnant donc tout le monde prend des
produits pour pratiquer du sien pour
faire son sport et ça c'est une forme de
dopage même si les produits sont pas des
produits interdits
un petit stimulant avant le jogging du
dimanche un tir montant après trois
cachets d'aspirine par ci deux barres
vitaminées par là il n'y a pas forcément
dopage mais la prise de produits
pharmaceutiques se généralise et dans
son travail de sensibilisation auprès
des jeunes sportifs frédéric nordman a
parfois des surprises
j'ai rencontré un entraîneur de l'équipe
de gamins qui n'hésitait pas à mettre du
liant 11 ans dans la flotte de ces
gamins la mi temps parce qu'ils
pensaient que ces gamins j'aurais moins
bien s'il leur donnaient de l'eau claire
ça c'est un comportement extrêmement
courant si frédéric est guéri c'est en
partie grâce au travail réalisé à
l'hôpital laennec par le centre monte
cristo qui soigne les héroïnomanes sur
les 100 derniers patients du dr
lowenstein 20 sont ou ont été des
sportifs accomplis
la pression du résultat la volonté de
guérir vite après une blessure
les ont conduits à prendre des produits
interdits le sport à l'heure actuelle
est une machine à faire beaucoup plus de
perdants que de gagnants
et encore les gagnants vont pas si bien
que certains gagnants au mal et on peut
se demander combien il faut de maradona
ou de ben johnson pour rappeler que
derrière tout champion il ya un individu
un individu qui est un homme souvent
perdus et presque toujours exploité la
loi du silence se brise tout doucement
les langues commencent à se délier
le sport n'est pas forcément synonyme de
pureté ou de propreté et plus de quatre
siècles après montaigne il est toujours
aussi difficile d'avoir un esprit sain
dans un corps sain
aux etats unis les deux aéronautes qui
tentaient leur premier tour du monde en
ballon dû sauter en parachute et sont
sains et saufs la poche d'hélium a
éclaté l'équipage aurait tant que
d'acquérir selon les images
l'un des deux hommes n'est que blessé au
visage
impressionnant le thème est rarement
évoquée par le cinéma anglais il s'agit
de l'attraction de certains enfants
d'immigrants pour l'extrémisme musulman
le film s'appelle meissen de fanatiques
et lui vient de sortir sur les écrans ou
béret et de l'air christian teint
l' empire britannique avait le goût de
l'expansion coloniale la diversité de
ces immigrants était la mesure de ses
ambitions d'un autre temps on compte
outre manche plus de deux millions et
demi de musulmans moins qu'en france
mais venus d'horizons plus lointains
dont une minorité revendique violemment
son identité
maïssane fanatiques nous entraîne au
nord de l'angleterre
un père d'origine pakistanaise ci est
inséré sans garder d'illusions le fils
refusant le prix de l'humiliation et du
racisme répondent à l'appel de
l'intégrisme
quand way la chine si de toutes les
flammes
il ya beaucoup de gosses asiatique
musulmans ou même indiens qui se sentent
exclus aujourd'hui il se tourne vers
l'autoritarisme religieux pour se
trouver une identité une sorte de
famille un peu plus solidaire rien ne
semble pouvoir rapprocher ces deux
mondes
rien ne peut désormais réconcilier ces
deux hommes alors que le fils choisi le
camp de l'obscurantisme et de la
violence
le père se dégage pour la première fois
du carcan de ses origines et des
préjugés de sa patrie d'adoption
accrocher des carabines est restée la
vraie menace aujourd'hui c'est le
racisme est pas l'extrémisme nous devons
vraiment travailler à la construction
d'une europe démocratique libéral où
chacun pourra se sentira pas d'effets
spéciaux pas d'acteur top model meissen
de fanatiques est un film tout simple
certes d'une facture un peu trop
classique mais il a le mérite de traiter
avec intelligence un thème qui dérange
dans une angleterre surtout préoccupé de
son renouveau économique
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres
lionel jospin n'apaise pas la grogne des
chômeurs qui appelle à continuer le
mouvement manifestation nationale prévue
mardi parmi les mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement
un milliard de francs pour à fond
d'urgence sociale un contrat local de
sécurité pour mieux lutter contre les
violences urbaines des adjoints de
sécurité en renfort dès aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs communes
à l'initiative de jean pierre
chevènement dans un instant la météo
sophie davant attend toujours doux et
lumineux
20h50 maigret avec bruno cremer de mât à
7h dans thé ou café catherine ceylac
reçoit josiane balasko et daniel
ceccaldi pour un grand cri d'amour
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain
vasseur merci de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée
question hockey talent